what happened in Cleveland here Chris
you know Dan my understanding is that
there was a disconnect between tyloo and
the front office / ownership about who
should be playing right now
I mean tie as you saw from you know some
of the Instagram posts after the fact
but there's a strong bond between Ty and
the vets on that team the JR Smith with
your chills the Kevin love's I mean
these guys went to you know four
straight finals together and the message
coming from the front officer what I'm
able to understand is that we need more
of you know Collin Sexton you know we
need to play these young guys as we you
know effectively tank and and try to
rebuild that way so I think that's where
the disconnect was greatest and that's
what cost eyes job weight they want to
tank and therefore they don't want the
veterans to play because then they don't
have as good a chance to of tanking if
you have good players out there well I
don't think the word tank was never used
necessarily but it's you know when
you're playing a rookie point guard 35
minutes at night or whatever it is
that's what you're doing I mean you know
Philadelphia did the same thing for four
years when you when you're sitting
you're more talented guys in favor of
younger players we're going to make more
as mistakes you know it's just a matter
of semantics to me man six games in if
they went two and four does he keep his
job one in five does he keep his job I
really think that it all depends on who
is playing at that point I do I mean I'd
say I don't think it was but the catch
team stinks like they're really bad and
nobody surprised did that I mean you
couldn't like exhume Red Auerbach and
have him on the sidelines and have it be
successful so that it's it is what it is
I just think that that the ownership in
the front office wanted to see more of
the young players and I don't think ty
was willing to do that the headline of
the first two weeks of the season is
what I mean there's a lot of surprises
for me it's it's Toronto looks like the
team to be the East I mean you Kauai is
Ben Kauai and that's you
that's a team and I was talking to an
executive out this last night whose team
played them he said when you play that
team everybody knows their roles and
that's where they differentiate
themselves in the south attract now the
Celtics figure each other out and see
who does what never he's kind of
deferring a little bit too much Kauai
step into that DeRozan role the bench
guys are still there so they you know
know exactly how they want to play and
and how they want to play together so
they're I mean I think as good as
they've been early it's been the biggest
story to me I also had to laugh when you
had people say you know time to panic
with the Lakers when they lost their
first three games and then they won a
couple and then were we still panicking
and then now you lose and are we
panicking again is it going to be this
way is it game to game the entire first
half of the season with the Lakers I
mean every team LeBron has ever played
on has been game to game number when
they were nine and eight with Miami in
that first journey you know everyone's
firing Erik Spoelstra at that point I
mean same thing with Cleveland I mean
it's just we micromanage LeBron in ways
I don't think we've ever micromanage any
player in the history of sports all that
being said this is what they are they're
they're they're an inconsistent team
that I don't think has the talent level
to be a playoff team in the Western
Conference two fundamental things that I
saw coming into the season they
struggled what they have won they don't
defend there they're trying to mask it
with pace they play the third fastest
pace in the NBA and you know just
putting up you know huge numbers but
they're giving up well over 100 points
in every single game that they played in
and I don't look at that team and see a
whole bunch of plus defenders out there
they're gonna make them get better as
the season progresses they're also 25th
in the league in three-point shooting
and I don't look around that roster and
see a bunch of great three-point
shooters they're going to emerge as the
season progresses certainly the bronze
gonna get better the 20% and who's not
probably better than 28% but yet they're
not a great three-point shooting team
and if you pull the three well they
don't defend well either higher a
playoff game in that conference talking
to Chris Mannix from Yahoo Sports senior
NBA writer there was a report that Jimmy
Butler has assurances from now the owner
Glen Taylor of the Timberwolves that he
will be traded
you believe that I don't believe
anything out of this this story anymore
I mean it's like every day there's a
leak coming from Butler's camp that that
you know makes it seem like he's out the
door but then you have to go back to one
unclad part of this that's the tomte but
it doesn't want to trade him and it may
come to kind of a loggerhead with
Thibodeau and Glen Taylor where you know
Thibodeau will say you could we will
trade him but you have to fire me too
and get me out the door because I don't
think kids cares about dysfunction
around the team I don't think he cares
about the locker room dynamic or
whatever the drama is right now at the
moment in Minnesota he knows that Ginny
Butler is his best two-way player and if
he's gonna have any chance at making it
run say the second spot in the West
which I think it's wide open this year
he's got a Hamptons brother on that team
so the report of four first-round picks
which you know it's insane its own its
own its own way that's not going to get
it done for Tom Thibodeau because you've
got to include a starting level player
that he can plug into that mixture a
place you love it yeah I agree because I
said look if Huston can give up these
four first-round picks for Jimmy Butler
I'd do that if I'm Houston but if I
wouldn't do it if I'm Minnesota oh come
on Dan didn't we go down this rabbit
hole once before
well what four first-round picks means
and how devastating it can be to a
franchise didn't we do this it doesn't
mean anything these are picks that are
gonna be in the in the mid to late 20s
probably and Houston has a change
Houston has a window here of what three
years to win a title
the next said the same thing I did this
story for us I years back the next set
the same thing those players were over
the hill that the nets god no no they
weren't
I mean look after the foul come on hold
on hold on after the fact we learned the
cage he had nothing left
Pierce still had something left at the
time Dan Deron Williams was in that kind
of Chris Paul class we're still
comparing those two until Jones was a
high level guy over the cover store run
for SI on the cover it said who wants a
piece of em because so everything
there's a lot of people that believe
that team was a championship level team
at the time there's no way they could
have imagined
that it would have played out the way it
did do you think if the Rockettes get
Jimmy Butler that changes anything in
the West
it makes yes chase in the West they're
reached as number two but I've watched
Golden State over the weekend they're
playing the best basketball I've seen
them play in the Kevin Durant error
right now especially between those two
Durant and courier just completely
instinct I don't think it gets them a
championship and more importantly than
for this purpose is why I think it's
dangerous those four first-round picks
Jimmy Butler's been banged up in recent
years got some knee problems dealt with
some injury issues Christmas presumably
you give him a five two year contract
right you sign in to the max level deal
that he's that he really wants at some
point with Jimmy Butler you're going to
be paying for past production so how
many years you squeak out of a top level
Jimmy Butler Chris Paul team pause what
33 Jimmy Butler's gonna be in his early
30s I think you've given yourself like a
cooz year window to win a championship
but after that all bets are off so if
that's 4th pick Dan is in like 2022 you
think that's gonna be a bad pick I'm not
gonna do that but you're trying to win a
championship this is all about in a
moment trying to win a championship I
mean am I talking to Billy King right
now I mean this is like this is the same
thing the Nets did and I understand what
they were Julian Bond ler is is far
better than any of those Celtics who
were dealt and you know that and we know
that a hundred percent but I think
you're diminishing what we thought the
Nets were at that time we thought the
Nets were a legitimate title contender
with that group and within two years
because of injury because of
inconsistency those picks became
disastrous for them but I know the
Rockets are title contenders I know that
I didn't know that with the nets
I know that Jimmy Butler can play at a
high level higher than any of those
Celtics could and if you're the Rockets
what do you do just decide to this is
our roster and then that's it that we
don't we're not going to try to win a
championship here well I mean it's
hindsight but I wouldn't have made the
moves they did in the offseason I would
have paid Trevor Ariza I mean
team who was up 3-2 going into the the
Chris Paul injury I don't have done that
now it just seems like these are I mean
look if it all depends to me Dan on how
many usually brother I mean I just if
you can get four years out of him
playing at this Jimmy Butler type level
you take the deal if it's less than that
if we're dealing with injuries cluster
Chris Paul takes a step back I think it
becomes a pretty risky still number you
can't it's not like it's four
first-round picks in a row right you
can't do that in the NBA it's got to be
every other year and so there could be
two picks in the 2020s there turn out to
be great picks for the Timberwolves
thank you Chris it's great to talk to
you all right let's do it again
that's a Chris man you know who sports
senior NBA writer for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]